Oh Brianna ASAP rocky are apparently
dating yeah that's the news guys you
know that means rihanna is [ __ ] to do
some weak-ass drug with the week stroke
game
that means rihanna right now is getting
[ __ ] worse then I could [ __ ] her
that's every aisle eight 15 year old boy
on tick-tock right now
damn so have a chance so have a chance I
love all the people that were like you
know trying to clown ASAP for that video
only a stroke as bad as like it's
[ __ ] ASAP rocky dude already like
fifth girl he [ __ ] that day yeah that
guy is [ __ ] beautiful it's not that
good stroke yeah what the [ __ ] probably
just stand there you vote a girl is not
ever gonna like walk away from [ __ ]
ass at rocky and complain that it was
bad it's gonna the sentence is gonna go
it was bad but I [ __ ] ASAP rocky yeah
and it's like grin here to here he
looked good yeah because he looking back
to like this drug is terrible but and
this is him smiling yeah cause she's
like I can I could do this you think you
Fox with like a sick ass fit on it just
pulls his dick for the fly and I mean
definitely yeah yeah definitely
Jews leave take off his jeans yeah got
some crazy [ __ ] a VVS rhinestone gene
said you know [ __ ] looks like a
bedazzled
you got to think like eighty percent of
those kids or whoever was like yo ASAP
rocky stroke game we they're saying that
as they're like [ __ ] their
flashlights yeah you should trash honey
way better we had a I don't even know if
husband we had a lyrics conversation
about flashlights yesterday or two days
ago we dead yeah we dead yesterday I
don't even know those two days those two
days ago yeah the longest music session
we've ever had
you